so what made you want to move Japan in
the first place because I like I assume
you discovered teaching English because
that was one of the most prevalent ways
to like get to move to Japan right it
was um well for me I have a very unique
history I guess it's very unusual when I
was 19 I was in college right I had to
think about that yeah and I was taking a
Japanese lesson because I just had seen
some Japanese movies I thought were cool
and I was like oh you know that sounds
cool Battle Royale was still really
popular and yeah Kira Kosovo films my
buddies and of course video games
um so I took this Japanese class and I
was completely failing it I'm so bad
it's a theme throughout my
but they said the the teacher said hey
we need somebody to be a host family
because this person lost their original
host family because of a disagreement or
something right and I was thinking damn
that would be so sick I could like play
Street Fighter with this dude and we
could hang out all the time and I could
learn Japanese and I was like I'll do
that that sounds cool and it ended up
being a girl who lived it with my mother
and I for like two or three years okay
and whoa and I had in three years well
we got that's long for a host family
right yeah yeah like usually they don't
lost it's like maybe like three to six
months like a week or something a week
no no I think on average it's like maybe
three months I guess from that distance
I did it with like Irish kids and that
was we did that for like a week and that
was too much
I did not get along well with my Irish
Council yeah because uh Sydney did the
same thing as well she had a she had a
host uh she was a host family as well
all right and she had the dress she had
the choice uh between uh her parents
wanted to uh become a host family for
someone abroad and Sydney was going
through a wee place here she was like
pick someone Japanese
yes
the Japanese one please well I'm
thankful that she didn't have a catalog
or I would have never come to Japan
because because I don't think she would
have chose me but my mom was you know my
my sister had just moved out and so it
was kind of cool because I was living in
the basement like any normal American
Boy and of course and then she took like
my sister's old room upstairs and so we
I think it was a bit longer even when I
went to college in a different city uh
she stayed at the house and stuff wow
but she said you know your family's been
so kind to to me why don't I introduce
you to my family and you visit Japan so
I was like 20 21 and she lived in
Yokohama which is a really nice place to
visit and I I loved it man it was such a
transformative part of my life yeah
where I was like studying acting and I
could read the tea leaves so to speak I
was like what year was this song this
was
1964 no I'm kidding uh
was 2004 or 2009
this was so different well yes it was
that was when Akihabara was still the
electricity yeah because when I went to
Akihabara it was insane when I was
growing up Akihabara was a place of
Legend every video game magazines that
egm or game players or PSM tips and
tricks they would have a correspondent
from Akihabara talking about the sites
and the games and the arcades this is so
cool it was there was like three made
cafes as opposed to now where there's
300 men yeah you went there and it was
the HobbyTown so anyway I had a great
experience and I said you know if acting
doesn't work out
I will I will come to Japan someday
again so I visited two more times and
then at 26 I finally got my college
degree a little later than some would
say
um but I I made the move and that's
where I started and in nigata which on
the west coast of Japan but that's why I
was interested in coming for sure okay
so did you go through with the jet
program like everyone else I applied and
and that sounds lame I uh I made it to
the interview phase but I graduated in
Winter as opposed to like spring or
summer like most students yeah and their
interviews are in like late fall so they
said you've made it to the interview
phase but it would take about nine more
months to have oh [__] so I was like
okay I'll put that in my back pocket but
I'll check out like newsletters or
online sources and if I can find a
opportunity we'll see how it works and
right mine was marketed as beautiful
beach town in the western coast of Japan
and I was like I was like let's [__]
go really where what's your sauce yeah
it wasn't with chat this is weird it was
the heart Corporation and uh we don't
know yet I think it may have not even
been a real company but uh they the dude
in his face actually you arrived it was
crazy right well man it was such a mess
so you know I got hired the day before
the earthquake oh [__]
then the plane and the moving was pretty
rapid from there and so I was trying to
contact this Source but not be because
they were in um it was like kind of it
was an ibadaki was where their head
office was which was kind of close
enough to the earthquake yeah right and
I was messaging him I was like ah
do I how do I do I have a job but don't
answer me unless it's you can or yeah
what am I doing and he was like yes come
to Japan and I was like I don't have a
Visa or anything he's like we'll sort it
later and I was like
so when I got there I was on a tourist
visa and I showed up and I took a bus by
myself to ibadaki and it was still
struggling from the yeah the earthquake
and we went into basically a basement
and there was still manila folders and
and files all over the floor and the guy
was just you know the the definition of
an expat who has been in the teaching
game too long he was just like okay
everyone uh you're you're going to uh
and I was like he got done he's like uh
yeah and I was like okay sure and we had
a two-day trip oh it was bad it was
really good we had two days of training
um most of it was centered around this
is a sad thing it was uh don't be
inappropriate to the children which is
and I was like yeah I kind of figured
that part out is that you're gonna tell
me bro the course for that what was that
well that was like it was like seven of
the eight hours was examples of what not
to do like for example okay don't show
pornography that's I was like wow thank
you for telling me I had that one on my
bingo yeah well the Italian Senate
all right
I guess you're out of there now I was
like well three terabytes gone
the next one may surprise you you're not
supposed to date students
wow
and I was sitting there thinking
there was no there was actually limited
electricity even because there was they
were doing like energy but I was
thinking like and I did ask I was like
what is why are you telling us the most
obvious information ever and he was like
well the previous people who were
teaching they all lost their contract
because of a guy or girl I don't know
who it was but like did something
inappropriate so the entire and it
wasn't that company it was a different
and then they got hired so my contract
was only for three months so we were The
Replacements and I guess they were very
eager not to have something happen any
problems yeah but I was like okay well
what about the actual like um teaching
part do I don't have any experience do I
need any of that he's like you'll be
fine
how many schools do I have like just
like is it a high school he's like you
have seven and I was like what that's
what I said and I was like what does
that mean he's like you have five
elementary schools and two junior high
schools and I was like but there's only
like five days in a working place and he
was like oh that's right you're gonna go
like you're going to switch schools at
lunch time and uh you have to do these
things whoa this was a very exciting
face and so then after those two days
where you learn very exciting because
you're terrifying well yeah it was but
you know you were in it
I'm in Japan I was like I don't have a
phone I don't have a carrier I didn't
have a phone for my first four months
weird being like totally disconnected
from your home yeah it was and it was it
was tough because you're coming from
something like I had my entire life's
possessions in like two or three
suitcases and uh imagine you know you
weebs with your toys and your pillows
and your whatever the [__] weaves or
whatever you guys have you I don't know
clothing and then you have to
consolidate all of that down into two
suitcases right yeah oh well then that's
not as cool as it made it sound that's
uh
iPhone 3S had just come out to put this
in perspective there are probably some
kids watching this that'll like the what
the what yeah I know it's so bad and I'm
so old but um it's cool though but they
gave me a car and they put a washing
machine in the back and they said just
drive like eight hours that way and I
was like what do you mean
I gave you a car yeah yeah I had to have
a car because my my classes were you
know jootsu where I was staying there's
not a one I mean once you're outside of
Target yeah I know but like they just
told us where did this car come from
documents I'm sure you do need them you
know we're just it was like yeah so I
just found a car on the side of the road
you found this company through Google
right it was actually on Craigslist or
some [__] like that that's the name no
I'm kidding it was actually similar it's
called um Ohio Sensei and it was a like
a monthly newsletter that they would
send out that had listings of
opportunities okay 95 of them were if
you're in Japan here
there was like one that was like We'll
hire anyone I was like that's me so I
don't have any experience driving in
Japan I don't even totally familiar with
all the rules not to mention it's the
wrong it's on the left side right the
wrong side yeah did you have a driver's
license I did I was a pizza delivery man
in the United States so I uh I'm no
stranger but did you have a
international license
wait a minute no I'm kidding I I did I
had it okay for Americans those only
last a year and then you can't yes
everyone yeah yeah oh is that right okay
yeah after that do you guys have to take
the test yeah we don't have to take a
test for the UK but uh in Japan yeah we
got to do the whole thing yeah in Japan
if you move here because you're a
resident you're for the first year
you're allowed to use an international
driving license and then after that
you're not allowed to use it yeah you
either have to get a Japanese driver's
license or you have to convert your
current license
okay well
um I had that piece of paper yeah I
drove West or wherever it was and then I
finally after about 11 or 12 hours I hit
the coastline I hit the coastline and
then I had to go south because I
overshot it but like you I got there and
um it was kind of crazy because there
were six other teachers with me
um and we were meeting in like literally
a basement and it it even kind of
reminds me of like a cinematic thing
with like The Swinging lamp and it was
like very low light and like you see
people's faces for like two seconds
some people are smoking in there and I
was late and they were like you know so
our final guest and I'm like oh it's
literally like a movie
we were looking at this giant map of
nigata and everybody had a color code
that that signified where we were and I
was like it's like it's like Reservoir
Dogs I'm like Mr Pink or something I was
like I was like I don't see my my things
like anywhere and they're like no you
have to do that because you've already
driven here and I was like okay and then
we like unfurled the map like three
squares and I was over in the mountains
and it was like the most uh kind of
isolated part right right yeah oh yeah
the elementary school had 31 students
total so had one first grader it had
like five or six seconds yeah and I was
like hi I'm your English teacher you
know and it was
um to my great surprise though I started
at the junior high school and it's I get
there and they had a grand welcoming for
me and I've mentioned this story before
on my streams or things but I walk out
into this this theater this Auditorium
or gym or whatever and there's like the
brass band playing all eight of them you
know there's like a kid hitting the
symbols and then there's like the
teachers and everyone's clapping and
there was this one kid by like the the
like the wings of the stage yeah he was
like looking for someone and they were
like hit it and he like yanked it down
nothing happened and he like did it
again and it unfurled this ginormous
poster that said welcome Peter
I was like uh given my recent training
I was like better and I was like ah oh
man that's not my name but I'll go with
it oh my God
I guess I'm better now is here let's go
and so I was like all right this is
going to be interesting and you know
some of the things if you're thinking
about being a teacher you need to
realize is you have like a school lunch
which is made by like a nutritionist and
you might get like fish heads or you
know a really healthy thing a balanced
diet yeah a balanced diet and you get
like a carton of milk you don't get a
separate lunch from like the teachers so
it's it's very and you got to eat with
the kids a lot of the time yeah you go
to different classes and you're like
sitting in and you're like okay I'm too
fat for this [__] and you're like uh Hey
kids how you doing and you're like and
you don't know how to use chopsticks
maybe or yeah you know there's a lot of
things you don't know you're already
starting in the deep end culture
differences yeah yeah and so for me I
had to do a lot of farming and
agriculture work my because you're in
the mountains because I'm in the
mountains right right so I had to teach
them like the names of animals they may
Slaughter or raise I guess or animal
husbandry or like equipment or you know
and then they were like well it's time
for you to go out to the fields and
plant some rice or you know we're gonna
do hard backbreaking labor like what
it's actually shocking the amount of
like schools that still do that to this
day yes I mean in the mountains they
still do that what kind of stuff so for
the undul kai which is the sports
festival we planted our own rice so that
by the Harvest time we could enjoy our
our the fruits of our labor
that's cool it's also because like a lot
of these like kids that grow up in these
kinds of environments they end up
working in the Farms yeah anyway or they
go to like high schools that are like
agriculture based or like colleges that
agriculture-based so they're just like
well let's implant this knowledge into
the while they're young because they're
probably going to end up in that
occupation anyway and the English
teacher who's there by accident
and uh learn our culture do our work
well it was tough because I showed up in
like a suit and I remember uh you know
I'm like hey what's up in there and it's
brutally hot it's not a beach town this
is not a resort it's the most humid City
on planet Earth I swear yeah and uh I
was like they're like today we're gonna
run around this giant you know like two
or three kilometer field that was like
their harvesting field but ever every
morning the students and teachers all do
three laps to like promote I don't know
health and I was like I'm wearing like
you know a suit and he was like the the
principal really nice guy he was like oh
that is
and he was like I think I have some old
soccer shorts and he got me some umbros
and umbros are like what I remember from
like eight years old which are like
these sequenced soccer shorts yeah and I
am not the same size of uh a thin
Japanese man and I put those things on
and it was like the tightest like shorts
I barely got my thigh food you know them
and now I'm like and so I'm running yeah
who's that new teacher so I'm like
running in like dress shoes and umbros
in a suit and or a shirt with a tie yeah
and I'm like okay I've made a terrible
mistake but these parts I actually
enjoyed these kids had a real real
Charming quality to them they were very
innocent they were very intelligent and
they actually taught me a lot of things
but I needed to quickly learn that I am
not a teacher I am not I'm not here to
promote a lot of the concepts that you
would learn as an English student in
your schools I'm here to provide the one
thing and I think a lot of English
teachers who come here make this mistake
you got to remind yourself what is the
one thing that a native English speaker
has that Japanese teachers do not and
that you can feel and know the language
right yeah so you can make it
interactive you can make it fun and it
doesn't have to be about grammar and
vocabulary and writing stuff it can be
yeah but yeah so that's I think a lot of
people come here with the expectation of
oh well you know I'll be a teacher no
you will not you will be planting rice
and and gym shorts or you will be
welcomed with banners that say Pedder or
you know driving to new places but I
think it has gotten better the last 10
years certainly since when I showed up
yeah
a lot more mainstream that's for sure
yeah it certainly has and uh but even
then I'd say English teaching was a
massive industry even probably bigger
than it is now due to some changes that
they've made with the way acai was work
so
um do you want me to continue this yeah
yeah yeah
I'm sorry um I've never heard the like
the entire process from beginning yeah
yeah well one second I don't know I just
need a drink